All right.
Welcome to the program.
We are back from vacation.
We'll have a lot of new stuff happening for
you this year
and where I want to start today is I want
to talk about the future of the United States,
but not, I mean the Trump is part of it, but
that's not really what this story is about.
I know that now when we talk about the future
of the country, very often it relates to Donald
Trump.
Has Donald Trump irreparably done a, B or
C or how will we recover from Def that Donald
Trump has done?
That's not really what this is about.
This is, this is a bigger picture story, but
importantly, it's also not about predicting
the future in any particular sense.
Humans are notoriously bad at predicting the
future.
It's not just economists.
I'm talking about, we've talked about how
economists are bad at predicting the future
of the economy, but with change happening
more and more quickly, predictions about what
humanity will be like or what the United States
will be like in 50 years.
In a hundred years, in 500 years, it's increasingly
pointless to do that.
Type of thing.
Any predictions about this will definitely
be, or this will never be, these are not useful
predictions to make.
So for example, when Donald Trump said during
his last state of the union address that the
United States will never be a communist country
and, or maybe he used the word socialist and
everybody cheer, Republicans cheered.
Other than that being a really ignorant thing
to say because there's really no risk of that
happening in the immediate, like the idea
that the country is on the verge of becoming
a socialist country.
That's not the case to say something will
never happen.
Makes very little sense because it's 500 years
is a long time.
A hundred years is a long time.
Fair enough.
I think we understand that what this story
is about is about the future of the American
political system.
Now, there is no doubt that many of us believe
elements of the current system are unstable
and precarious and at some point it could
be natural to think the system will collapse
or evolve and many people feel that there
is an inevitability to that.
So I'll give you some specific examples.
Marxists have long held that eventually the
proletariat is going to revolt against the
bourgeoisie.
In capitalist countries like the United States,
the system will collapse and in its place
will be installed a Marxist system of government.
Okay?
That's an example of a Marxist idea of the
inevitability of what will be the future political
system.
Free market capitalists on the hand who believe
that the ideas of social democracy are fraught,
untenable, uh, bad ideas.
The free market capitalists often imagine
that as those ideas fail, be it single payer
health care or whatever, society will move
more and more in the direction of total free
market capitalism.
More generally, history has shown us that
nation States often don't last forever, right?
Whether we're talking about the fall of Rome
or the Ottoman empire or there are many other
examples, and it is true.
A country can be destroyed by war.
A country can be taken over, it can be annexed,
it can be divided up into multiple smaller
countries as we saw happen during the 1990s
in Europe, for example.
But it's important for any good activists
to understand that it's called the status
quo for a reason and things can basically
remain as they are and this is actually a
desired outcome.
This is a goal for many elements of society
that wield influence, and I'll explain what
I mean because this is really important stuff
to understand.
We look at healthcare in the United States
and we look at medical bankruptcy, the increased
cost of health insurance, the terrible plans
that costs, you know, 500 bucks a month for
a $10,000 per year deductible or whatever,
and we think this can't go on forever.
Like eventually this has to collapse, but
maybe not.
There are very powerful interests that want
the system to basically remain this way, but
they recognize that it's not sustainable indefinitely.
In other words, we say this is not indefinitely
sustainable.
Those who want the current system also recognize
it's not indefinitely sustainable if the trajectory
continues and they can choose to do just enough
to keep basically the same system going.
I'll give you another example.
We look at the cost of college, which has
skyrocketed some colleges costing 60 70 $80,000
a year.
Maybe my numbers are outdated and it's even
more.
We project out that growth and we say, this
can't go on.
This is a system that's going to implode on
itself because college will soon cost hundreds
of thousands of dollars a year.
People won't be able to afford it, or they'll
take out student loans, which they will never
be able to pay because wages are not increasing
in parallel with the cost of college, so it'll
collapse and we'll start over hopefully with
something better or the powers that be, which
include colleges, student lending, institutions
and others can tweak what we have put in some
subsidies, raise wages a little bit to make
expensive college degrees just slightly more
worth it to basically perpetuate the system
that we have now have huge profits for lenders,
schools and students who get degrees with
which they can't really get ahead and take
decades to pay the loans off if they ever
are able to pay them off.
The entire point here is the assumption that
an unsustainable system will collapse, that
then we can change into something we like
ignores that the status quo is not only appealing
to many systems of power, but that it will
be a great motivator to them to fix little
things to avoid the collapse, just to perpetuate
the status quo.
This is how they will throw bones to the masses
every once in a while.
This is part of the same system that prevents
people from being able to afford really getting
out there and protesting big time for massive
systemic change.
The system works to keep people so day to
day when it comes to their salaries that they
can't take time off to go and protest, but
then if things get too hot, they will throw
us a bone here or there.
Things can basically stay the same or close
to it for a long time.
And as I've said before, it's always harder
to win when you want to do stuff and the other
side wants to keep things the same.
But knowing this better arms us to be activists
we're working against, we're working against,
and my pronunciation was a little bit incorrect
there.
We're working against not just people who
want to change things for the worse for the
most number of people, but there are huge
forces that we are fighting that merely want
to tweak the edges to basically maintain the
status quo.
That includes corporate powers and it includes
moneyed interests, so understand that the
collapse is not inevitable because a strategy
is doing just enough to avoid the collapse,
but basically perpetuate the status quo and
a big part of this is economics and we're
going to dig into some economics next.